[Music]
welcome welcome to container once
severus anywhere I'm steering Giannini a
product manager on the service team at
Google cloud hi I'm Ryan Gregg I'm also
a product manager on the service team
cats out of the bag we can say that it's
about cloud run now right okay we can
say it now hopefully you're in the right
place if you came to learn about quad
run this is a um but let's let's give
you a little bit of background before we
start on that so for over ten years
Google has been investing in the
developer experience for running on the
cloud our very first product for Google
cloud actually before it was Google
Cloud was app engine which was you know
invented before the word serverless was
even a thing
it allowed developers to write code and
run it at scale in the cloud without the
need to worry about infrastructure since
then we've also released cloud functions
which is a you know excuse me it
functions as a service based product and
these two together have allowed
developers to understand the benefits of
service compute allowing them to focus
on their code and not worry about the
infrastructure that is necessary to run
that code our customers probably all of
you here today or many of you here today
have been very successful using these
platforms to run your business and
recognizing the value that App Engine
and cloud functions provide their
engineering teams on lowering the
requirements of running production code
we've even heard people say you know
Google is my sre I don't have to worry
about having that role in my company but
serverless wasn't always accessible to
everybody there were restrictions and
limitations when on using our service
platforms that caused problems and we
often heard from customers things like I
have these existing binaries that I want
to be able to use or there's a
particular coding language that is
optimal for the tasks that I'm using
when is that going to be supported or
even Java developers maybe Python
developers probably remember you know
maybe it wasn't even the whole language
that was available in the service
platform it was just a subset of it so
you know there were there were
challenges and we
to make this more accessible to
everybody not just the people who could
fit the mold that we had but what is
cerberus how do we think of it as a
Google after all of the years of running
App Engine and cloud functions all of
the feedback from customers we've
developed a model for how we think about
service and it divides into two pieces
one is the operational model this is the
sort of way that serverless runs it's
the idea that you don't have to worry
about the infrastructure there's no
servers to provision no operating
systems to install none of those sort of
details of how things work at that level
it's also about managed security so
ensuring that you know Google takes care
of the details on how to secure your
production environment and then a really
important piece for many of you is
pay-as-you-go or pay only for usage the
idea that you aren't paying for
provisions and servers or provisioned
nodes but only the compute that you're
actually using and there's a programming
model aspect to this as well so this is
the developer experience it's moving
from being a traditional model to being
more service based being able to have
managed services that you leverage to
get your work done instead of bringing
it your own dependencies or even writing
those things yourself
it's about being event-driven so instead
of building monolithic applications that
are focused on the application think
about how the data flows through your
system and how you can attach compute to
the events that are generated by that
and then there's a third piece that we
think it truly means to be service at
Google and that is about being open it's
really the ideal of what service should
be and not so much what service has been
in the past so we want to make sure that
the developer experience is idiomatic it
feels natural to you as a developer
you're not constrained by what the
platform has to offer and also that it
should be portable you don't want to be
locked into a particular platform vendor
when you're using a service technology
you should be able to run it wherever it
makes the most sense for your business
and change your mind later on if you
want to this is the true value of
service all of these things so that you
can just focus on writing the code that
matters the core value of your business
and not have to worry about all the
other details separately though from
service happening
there's been another trend in the
industry
the rise of containers you know
containers over the last four or five
years have really picked up this is a
Google Trends graph showing like peak
interest at the top at 100 and you can
see we're at the current peak interest
for containers containers are if you
don't know what they are or a way to
easily move code and binaries between
environments so you can have the
confidence that the way that application
runs in one environment will carry over
to the next place that you run it so you
can have a CI CD system produce
containers for you validate that they
work and then literally take the same
code the same binary as the same
container package and run it in
production and get all the same
experience in fact it's become such a
great experience for developers and
operators alike that is now an industry
standard with a ton of tooling and
support and an entire ecosystem around
how you build and use containers and
while you can containerize just about
anything and the tools make this really
easy running containers not only so easy
there's orchestration platforms that you
need to deal with there's kubernetes
there's you know all of the api's and
lifecycle management that go into that
you have to think about how to scale
your application how to you know get the
most out of it with all of the stuff it
really means that you need an operator
running they're sitting there with your
code to make sure that it's running
correctly in production but staring what
if there was a way to do all of this
greatness with containers and get all
the benefits out of this without the
need for an operator what if developers
could do it on their own
I wonder what if it could be easier you
know what let's switch to the demo
screen what if I could simply from the
cloud console open the cloud run section
what if I could click a button the
deployment forms from opens and paste
the URL of a container image that I've
taught previously in my container
registry and then without doing anything
else without provisioning any
infrastructure
click create that's it
that's all we need to deploy a container
to cloud run no infrastructure to
provision in advance
no cluster creation no Yammer file and
boom we have it like literally did not
had the time to finish my sentence but
clarin has imported our container made
sure that it started and gave us back a
stable and secure HTTP endpoint to
invoke our container
let's open it it's running that's it
it's that simple to deploy an existing
container image to cloud one so yes we
are introducing at Google next 2019
cloud run bringing several s2 containers
thank you but you might wonder what can
I do with cloud run well overall the use
cases are very broad cloud run allows
you to deploy any stateless HTTP
container so that means that any HTTP
requests driven workload or workload
that you can invoke as synchronously
will be a good fit for cloud one this
kind of platform allows a wide variety
of use cases let's take a look at some
of them we can find two categories the
first one is what we call public
services today would be you want to host
a website automatically scaled to handle
the incoming traffic cloud on is great
for that you want to expose an API
endpoint the same a backhand for your
mobile app cloud run or maybe a simple
web hook that you use to receive a
github notification or maybe a a chat
bot this is also a good use case
everything that is automatically scaled
to handle the incoming traffic that
varies over time then there is a second
category of services those who are not
exposed to the Internet and those ones
are for example if you are breaking out
the
of your application you might have
created many microservices well what if
each of those microservices could scale
independently on demand to meet the load
that is needed from them so private
micro services are also a good fit
things that are not exposed to the
internet but that are part of your
overall cloud architecture and lastly as
I mentioned you can take those private
services but instead of invoking them
directly via HTTP you can use things
like web server or cloud tasks to do a
synchronous task execution where the
task is executed on their own demand
cloud run service so some of our alpha
testers have built many such use cases
for doing image transformation video
processing document processing all of
this is feasible with cloud one so over
this talk we are going to go about the
three main pillars of the cloud run
product we will see how it takes
containers and how it deploys them very
fast we will explain a bit what are the
benefits of containers we will show you
how this is a natively serverless
product and lastly you will see that you
can have the same clutter and experience
wherever you want it so let's get
started containers to production in
seconds this is the first pillar of
cloud 1 so yes
cloud run runs containers but why
containers right well first off they can
they allow you to run any programming
language so you are not restricted
anymore about the 5 or 7 languages that
Google cloud provides no no no any
language you want you can bring in I
brought a shell script into cloud one if
that is even the language but really
anything we've got Alex here we've got
rust you can try it out along with your
programming your favorite programming
language you can also use your favorite
library from this language but also from
the operating system because containers
also kept
the OS packages that you want inside
your PO container and more interestingly
any software any binary can also go into
your container and so this unlocks some
very interesting use cases well it's not
only about source code it's about
executing software in a service way
containers have a very large ecosystem
around them for example you will find
many many official base images on docker
hub that are officially maintained by
the language maintainer and we have to
acknowledge that today containers have
become an industry standard for
packaging distributing testing and
deploying software they are really in my
opinion better than a zip file so let me
welcome Thomas from Airbus who has been
part of the cloud run alpha program for
some month he's going to tell you how he
has been using aside from flying
airplanes as you probably already know
we also have several constellations of
optical and radio satellites that we
launched operate and provide services
around the data that's produced from
these sensors so let's talk about
service computing as you can see from
these vintage photos a user vitae goes
quite far back we have actually more
than 30 years of experience in storing
processing and distributing digital
satellite imagery
the nature of these several year long
programs when launching spacecraft
obviously the amount to quite a large
amount of stable and legacy code and
infrastructure but we started and moved
to public cloud platforms a few years
ago in that perspective I was very
excited when Darwin proposed us to be
part of the Alpha tester program for
cloud run to experiment ways in which we
could shift the our usage of compute
power for this use case as part of our
move to cloud platforms we recently
opened the one atlas
digital platform to provide paper use
api access to tasking satellites to
acquire imagery when specific conditions
omits time windows weather conditions or
recurrence we provide also download and
viewing access to raw and processed
imagery and we also provide extract
analytics from these rotators and
provide insight such as vehicle and
infrastructure detection change
monitoring precision agriculture or
deforestation monitoring now fueling
this platform actually requires
ingesting thousands of images every day
each one of those images is composed of
several billions of pixels and weighing
in several gigabytes of raw compressed
data under the scenes this leads to
quite a few challenges we want to
minimize storage size and we want to
efficiently respond to on demand access
to provide services without over
crediting compute instances
so let's explore a scenario where
children can help us with that
from this use case will be transforming
our raw imagery into the growing
industry standard that's called the
cloud optimized geo tips which is just
standard TIF file but where all the
imagery in metadata and pixel indexes
have been stored at the beginning of the
file to be compatible with our break
storage get range requests so our first
step is a batch process which will
ingest our romo tree and transform it
into these cloud optimized jutice files
into a cloud storage bucket jobs like
these will be continuously launched
whenever a new image becomes available
so now in the second phase in order to
be able to service request to clients
who want to only access parts of the
imagery we can deploy cloud run services
which are just docker images that
contain any low-level code this will be
able to access and transform the raw
pixel data from the jvitous files and to
fit the need of analytics jobs machine
learning training and inference rubs or
just interactive viewing so why is cloud
on a great fit for this use case being
able to run custom code on the serving
instances allows us to store the data
only once in a private format while
still offering the full range of
services at request time and this lowest
recurring storage cost by avoiding
duplication of data we also take
advantage of the scaling down of to zero
instances to be able to deploy as many
services as we need and the scaling up
of the instances also ensures that our
that
services are available and will absorb
any usage flags now in situations where
using public cloud isn't feasible the
key native roots that cloud run is built
upon well allows for code reuse and
shields us from locking so yeah all in
all we are excited to continue exploring
use cases that can be unlocked by
Caltrain and just can't wait wait to be
able to it's coming thanks Thomas thanks
a lot for being a part of the Alpha and
for the tremendous feedback you've
provided it's great to see how you are
leveraging the power of containers to
run your own binary in in the free auto
scaled environment that this cloud run
ok so let's go a bit about how we got
how we get to a container just maybe
that's obvious for some of you but let's
let's go over this the first thing is to
actually code your service on cloud one
we have a few requirements for you not a
lot but very important ones so we call
that the container runtime contract any
container that meets the those
requirements will be able to be deployed
and auto scaled on cloud one the first
one is that you're the request and the
pepcid events and any other a
synchronous tasks are going to be
delivered to your container via the HTTP
protocol on a given port so from your
side as a developer you have to listen
for it for HTTP requests on that part
you know how to do that right the other
very important point is that your
container should not rely on local state
of course you can use persistent storage
like databases and blob storage but
inside a container you can only rely on
temporary States the things that you
create because of the nature of the auto
scaling of Quran will not be here the
next necessarily the next time we invoke
your container
answer to stall state of course Google
that has many options fire store cloud
storage bigquery
so once you've built your app that meets
those requirements you can package it up
into a container image so we call that
the build phase so it's literally we
take all of those files run a command
and end up with a container image to do
that
the obvious tool that everybody knows
about is darker right darker build doc
approach this is what will transform
your local sauce into a container image
and push it to container registry the
Google Cloud has another product for you
that is a cloud build and cloud build
allows you to do just that
building your container except that this
time it's doing it in the cloud so you
don't even need to have the tooling
installed locally and once again like
any severus product you pay per use it
so when you don't build you don't pay
and you just pay for the time of your
builds so cloud build you can build
docker containers can do even more
complex builds and can also help you
automatically deploy your container
image to plan run and lastly we should
mention that containers are a very good
fit with continuous integration and
continuous delivery for example you will
build your container once test it
locally test it on your continuous
testing system push it to staging making
sure that everything is good on staging
and then take that exact same container
and deploy it to production the
container stays the same because that's
very important like the thing that you
tested is actually the thing that goes
into production so containers are a very
good tool for that and as I said cloud
build can help you achieve the
continuous integration and continuous
delivery but of course you can use
whatever tool you want to do that and
the last step is to run things so here
we go from one container image in a
Google cloud container registry and with
one simple command on or one click of a
button we deploy that to cloud run
on cloud 1 as you've seen you get a
stable is secured HTTP URL that you can
decide or not to expose to the Internet
and this happens as you've seen in just
a few seconds so the demo idea that was
really a hello world container I wanna
go over those steps with a real use case
let's switch to the demo screen place
yes ok so what I have here is just a bit
of Python code that is listening for
incoming HTTP request and then it's
invoking the OpenOffice because what all
micro-service is doing it's converting
Microsoft Word documents into PDFs to do
that we just call the office to give
together as a PDF there is another very
important file in my web service here as
you might know it's named akka file if
you don't know this don't be scared it's
super simple
let's take a look like literally 16
lines the first line is me using what we
call a base image the base image we will
contain already all of the the packages
and tools to run that particular
language in our case it's the official
Python base image maintained by the
Python community or maybe even the
Python maintainer we also have a line
where we install open office because as
you remember we had we invoked Open
Office so we first have to install it
from the regular Alpine package manager
and the last step is to specify your
start command that's what we have to do
start command tells how to actually
start or code so as you remember the
next step is to build that into a
container image I could use any tool but
I'm going to use the cloud build G cloud
they'll submit
I'll give it a tag and here I directly
point to a Google container registry
No there is a typo
it's submit ok so what's happening here
g-cloud is uploading my local sauce and
then triggering a remote build using
cloud build because OpenOffice you know
it's a quite a big software quite old it
has you know per beam Java it has a lot
of dependencies because of all of that
it can take maybe up to two or three
minutes to build so I will spare you
this I actually built it before the demo
so let's go to the next step the next
step is to deploy that to cloud run you
have seen the cloud console UI where you
can simply open a form and deploy here
I'm going to use the command line which
is G cloud beta because we are still in
better run deploy then I pass an image
so as I told you it's in Google Cloud
container registry run - intro is our
project name and the image that I built
before is PDF - service lets it enter
without more configuration jika is going
to ask me where do you want to deploy
and yes term as today it's only us 10
for 1 but stay tuned the other regions
are coming and it's suggesting for me a
service name well sounds good and it's
asking me do I want to allow a not
authenticated invocation to my service
this means do I allow anybody to invoke
that service and for the sake of the
demo I would I'm going to say yes to
show it to you in my browser right here
same as before
Claude run is importing your container
image it's creating a revision out of
the hood right now it's performing a
health check so that means it's making
sure that my container can start and
listen on the appropriate port you
remember on the listen for HTTP request
on the port on the given port and we are
done we get zoom out a bit a bit we get
a stable URL under HTTP let's open it
okay so this micro service converts Docs
to pdfs let's give it a doc upload it so
here my doc is he floated to my micro
service under the hood cloud run is
invoking OpenOffice to convert that dark
into a PDF and we get back a PDF so this
is the PDF that I got back from from
Chrome from from cloud on a viewed in
Chrome so that's it importantly here I
only had to pay when my service was
actually processing my request right now
it's scaled to zero I don't pay anything
it's only when I send the document and
when I process the document that I
actually am charged for the resource I'm
using during that processing time now we
had a head over to Ryan and can we
switch back to the slides to tell you
all about how this is severus and black
so that was a really cool demo of how
easy it is to take a container actually
even take Python code build it into a
container and deploy it using I don't
want to call it old I'll call it legacy
event vintage
that's now running service layer but you
know what does it mean by natively
service how do we think about how
service and the principles that I
defined earlier apply to Quadron so
first of all in the old world if you
were doing this on say compute engine or
even kubernetes engine you would have to
provision servers you'd have to think
about how to scale your workload and how
many servers you might need to be able
to transform thousands of PDFs on-demand
and really what that would mean is that
you would have to over provision the
number of servers that you bought
because you wanted to make sure that
there was enough capacity to handle all
of the load that was coming in the great
thing about cloud run is that you get to
do all that without having to worry
about any of it Google takes care of it
for you so you as a developer can just
focus on the code that matters and let
Google run all of the infrastructure we
give you a URL we autumn
we provision TLS certificates to give
you a secure endpoint we take care of
the redundancy and the automatic
failover we make sure that everything
keeps working so that your application
can scale with you has more and more
users start using your service
anis Terran said it's all paid for use
so what does that really look like you
know this is really simple right when
you have no requests there's no instance
of your application running the
container is put to sleep later when a
request comes in we'll quickly spin up
the instance of the container and start
serving traffic out of it and Cod run
supports concurrency so we can serve
multiple requests out of that same
container as more load happens we'll
create more instances of that container
to handle the load appropriately to keep
the latency low and then as a request
start to trail off we'll spin down
instances that container so you don't
have to keep paying for them what does
that look like though on the monetary
side well because of this auto scaling
mechanism we are able to give you a
paper use bidding model so that
literally means that you are only paying
for the resources that your service is
using in practice that means paying for
exact CPU exact memory and number of
requests performed during the processing
of those requests down to an increment
of a hundred millisecond once the
request is is out this is zero on your
bill for you and so as Ryan said cloud
run scales up so we wanted to show to
show you to show that to you of our demo
so let's switch to the demo screen what
we have here is a load testing tool that
will send many requests to or the
container that we just deployed so you
remember our container is ok our
container is processing PDF so you
remember that the PDF processing time is
not instant it takes a few seconds to
download the PDF and then transform it
download the dock and transform it into
a PDF by invoking OpenOffice
so what you see here I asked the load
testing tool to transform a thousand
PDFs in one minute and here what you see
is the scale-up of Quran which Open
Office being a quite big software you
know it takes some time to load so
that's why we see some higher latency
and then so here we have processed maybe
500 500 documents in in roughly 30
seconds and overall the latency yeah
Open Office takes 10 seconds to start
any process or PDF going forward it will
this time will go down because once a
request once a document has been
processed chlorin is able to reuse the
one instance in order to process the
next one so of course the startup will
the latency of the startup will take a
bit more time but once clarin has many
one instances for you over time things
will resettle down and here we processed
900 world documents that were stored in
Google Cloud storage in in a minute so
if you're interested in a scaling
performances Jason in his in his
breakout session went up to 10,000
instances with this client service
however here I just showed you sending
some load on a real use case which is
you know processing documents which
takes many seconds so that's why we
haven't seen that much high scaling but
overall you know a thousand PD thousand
PDFs in one minute is quite good it's
pretty cool that you took a two gigabyte
container with Open Office and you know
ran at serverless Lee
yeah the container is literally 2 gigs
and we looked at it ok so if I could
switch back to the slides so that was a
good demo about how hadron can auto
scale the third pillar of cloud run is
one experience where you want it which
is all about Portability and openness
that last pillar of the developer
experience that I introduced at the
beginning
and portability probably means different
things to different people in the room
so it might mean you know being able to
take your workload that you've started
on Prem and being able to move it to the
cloud or it could be about portability
of your own understandings and
experiences as a developer the great
thing about cloud run is that we wanted
to make sure that we satisfied both of
those constraints we wanted to make sure
that if a developer had to learn
something new to use this platform that
it could be reused on every project they
would work on in the future but those
skills could transfer again and again
and cloud run has a great promise but
I'm gonna take a side note here because
I've talked about containers and I've
talked about portability and if you know
Google at all you're probably thinking
like hey what about kubernetes
what about kubernetes engine that's what
I think of when I think of containers
and portability and you'd be right
kubernetes is a very portable platform
that supports running containers really
well today
however kubernetes is really fantastic
for the operator but doesn't do a whole
lot for the developer you still have to
think about how to scale your
application and how to do the network
programming how to manage all of the
details of how your container will run
on kubernetes and as Kelsey said you
know kubernetes is a great starting
place it's a great platform for building
other platforms it's not the end game
and this is where cloud run comes in
quad run and its component or its sister
component quad run on gke provide the
service experience anywhere that you
need it to be so like the quad run
managed service that Aaron was showing
you cloud run on gke gives you many of
those same benefits the same flexibility
in the control to run a container any
container on your kubernetes cluster you
get the same auto scaling benefits
including scaling to zero you can even
take advantage of gke specific features
so you can use custom machine types you
can ask for incredibly high amounts of
memory you can use hardware accelerators
like GPUs and TP use and you can have
access to the V PC networking all of
this lets you use the the benefits of
cloud run
on your existing kubernetes investment
so you can be fully serviced and run on
the regular house closed excuse me the
regular fully managed cloud run or you
can have that same developer experience
the same tooling the same API and run it
inside your kubernetes engine cluster
with quadrant on gke and now to tell you
about why this truly matters to our
customers I'd like to invite yeom from
birds up to the stage to tell you about
his use case company with 170,000
employees 50 countries the core
businesses of water waste and energy but
it's the branch company of various
pieces in IOT which design the devices
i've told to a deploy and configure on
field we process the data we stop them
and we diverse services to our customer
and all of this work on a low-power
network with our legacy protocol but
resources ones like six fox lower one
and an annuity the main business of
about hot water meter which represents
90% of our assets on fields with devices
designed to live up to 15 years on
lithium battery the devices have to be
deployed on feed by up lumber with
special training to plug and to
configure the devices this step takes
times and just take some money because a
small city is than what a meter to to
deploy that's why our customers don't
want to deploy
devices on each contract and want to
built devices always a life longer even
if he's not a belt of earlier I sprang
contractors and yes they also want to
decode the messages on the horn at the
end of the contract with about or via
that's why we have designed this
solution where I would hear about or
send us messages
so why book we push them to pubsubhubbub
stop some a pic of charger absurd push
the messages to the deeper to the
decoder to deduplicate
decoder and ver eyes the data and store
them into Bitcoin a scheduler trigger a
container to extract the data from bakui
and to load them to low latency database
for saving our websites the customer who
want to ask and to process the decoding
by the bison themself of the capability
to to deploy on the cluster with Geneva
this part and it could be on a DCP
provider or even optimized with CP web
to say to solution to the payor
container and for the miz's acquisition
is quite simple because it's
independence
simple and light and we have to absorb
some pic of charger that's why we were
truth to depend on an the fully managed
solution on the other hand the message
processing have to access to on Pam that
[ __ ] VPN and just who VDC and the
custom VPC are not yet implemented in a
free manager solution and we were to DP
it on GK moreover this decoding part I
have to access to a stateful resources
like ready spot or passes on volume
that's why he eats the best days the
short part
that preparation is quite difficult to
choose in DJs inference code and can be
quickly there's a few data and few
consumer but can be too long for the
free marriage solution is a mediator
mini data or customer to dates and not a
problem because with the same code the
same containers the same UI or the same
common name if you want it's really easy
to move from one station to another one
you only had to specify or not
doctor staff and the solutions is deploy
one solution and so on it's very easy
and really really good 16 thank you for
that the great use of cloud run and
cloud or non gke and really showing how
the portability of that experience is
important for you I'm gonna do a quick
demo of how this works just to prove the
everything that we said is true so if we
could switch back to the demo machine
we're back here in cloud console in
stands demo project and I'm going to
just create that same service that we
watched stare and deployed before so
I'll do GC r tayo run service and this
time instead of deploying it into the
fully managed service I'm gonna choose
from the location drop-down this highly
available with kubernetes cluster that
I've created before and I'll pick the
default namespace and I'll just click
create and so just like before with
cloud run fully managed now cloud run on
gke is deploying the service bringing in
the container creating a URL for me and
and making everything work and so now
this is actually running on my
kubernetes instance so if I click on
this URL you'll see here's the same
application it says running on cloud run
on gke just in case you didn't believe
me and then we can switch back and
actually look at the kubernetes UI and
i'll show you again if we go to
workloads for example you can see down
here the PDF service has been deployed
onto this kubernetes cluster and if I
switch over to services and for those of
you who are unfamiliar in kubernetes
land services are about networking not
about services you'll see the PDF
service here was a both an external name
and a co-star IP address so this service
that I created or that staring created
earlier is now running inside my
kubernetes cluster using the same API
the same UI the same experience I didn't
have to change anything but I could
easily deploy it into communities or
into managed service if we could switch
back to the slides
Thanks so you know we have shared
tooling we also have a CLI instead of
specifying the region that you want to
deploy into you specify the cluster name
that you want to deploy it's very simple
but how do we do all of this you know we
could have done it in a number of
different ways but we did this based on
the K native project which is an open
source project for building for service
building blocks on kubernetes that we
launched last year and next about eight
months ago and that provides the common
API the common runtime contract and an
reference implementation for how to do
everything that we've shown here today
it implements learnings from Google and
has more than 50 different companies who
have contributed into the project so
it's really taking this this standard
approach to how to run service workloads
on top of kubernetes and a try provides
this portable experience between both of
the managed services that we offer on
GCP
as well as being able to take it
anywhere that kubernetes runs you can
deploy k native onto that kubernetes
cluster and have the same tooling the
same api and everything working there in
fact that the developer keynote tomorrow
night Stan and I will show you how we
can even deploy that on to an IBM
cluster running manage K native and that
really emphasizes that Portability and
you can learn more by going to cañedo eV
[Music]